a fairground in Claver a town on the
german dutch border final preparations
are being carried out for a special Mass
Sasha ellinghouse is a Catholic priest
who ministers to fairground and circus
workers he's one of just seven in the
whole of Germany and the only one who
does this full-time his official title
is national pastor
father ellinghouse doesn't have a church
his parish consists of big tops and
fairgrounds throughout the country leave
it shall stood on the Shelf stiller
their counties and artistes dear sisters
and brothers welcome to the traditional
mass here this morning at tush boyos
bumper cars on clevo fairground def
amelia to spoil
hello beasts my father ellinghouse
celebrates mass where his parishioners
lead their lives on the fairground it's
early before the bustle of the day has
begun mass among the bumper cars is one
of the carnival workers traditions this
whole shallow father is naturally a
pastor is somebody we trust we ballin
all we need a priest to baptize our
children and conduct our weddings month
and amla yet in ahsha and Zasha is one
who travels from place to place he
adapts completely to our way of life
Steven he doesn't act like he's above us
he sympathizes with our problems when
the weather's bad or nobody turns up or
when some unfortunate accident happens
someplace he's right in the middle of
things and on the same level as us as
the church should be not otherworldly or
out of touch they'd fended off a
coldness it's a demanding ministry
father ellinghouse lives in Dortmund but
he's on the road nearly every day to
tend to his flock no mindful Humvee
Owens are kissing goodbye priests
generally work in churches they have
perished centers that offer a variety of
services and they invite people to come
ministering to circus artists and
carnival workers is exactly the opposite
the church goes out to the people to the
circus or fairground where they live and
work
once a carnival chaplain always a
carnival chaplain says father Manfred
Fox he was national pastor for ten years
until he turned his job over to Sasha
ellinghouse in 2014 now he has his own
parish again the traditional fairs in
southern Germany this is the marksman's
festival in folder where he gives a
blessing for man and machine Martin Fox
has always been enthralled by the
special atmosphere at Germany's
traditional fairs been highly diluted
common why I chose this ministry because
I have always felt a particular affinity
with carnival workers when I was a kid I
felt especially at home an hour
fairground and my parents took me to
other fairs my skin within a litter not
really we got to know a lot of people
there and we kept in touch when I got
older I used to help out and setting up
the booths and doing other things
selling tickets helping out where I
could give it oughta be seein
later he studied theology but he never
must touch with the fairgrounds
you guys to like you shape the I've gone
on every ride and tried all the games
there's hardly anything I haven't tried
and the operators asked me on how do you
like it how can we improve I'm
considered a bit of an insider don't
wanna be censored in inside and done as
an insider he enjoys their trust and he
understands the circumstances of their
lives
charlestown RI is this as a way of life
it's not just a job and you have to get
inside this way of life carnies have
their own view of religion based in the
belief that there is someone greater and
that some things are unpredictable such
as the weather and the number of
visitors lots me Lucy they can never be
sure how many will come they hope and
they plan that lots of people will come
but they can't be sure those are factors
they can't control so they have a kind
of fundamental trust in the greater
power opting cruiser and down
the next day 400 kilometers further
south in a small village near frankford
sasha ellinghouse visits the traver
family who run a small circus it's
midsummer when many germans prefer to go
swimming rather than visit the big top
so the trailers are taking a few days
off and using the time to have their son
baptized the baptistry is improvised and
the proud father provides a fitting
atmosphere while father ellinghouse
prepares the ceremony
the shop it up by my night aatish but I
have a portable altar of various cloths
candles and an altar cross and today I
have the holy oils for the baptism i
also have a small public address system
so that people can hear me and a CD
player and USB stick for the music why
even have a keyboard if there's somebody
who can play the organ but today there
isn't anybody so we'll just have to make
do with recording music this must be the
80 if their 90th time I've set up this
altar and it's always different
depending on whether there's a baptism
or a mass or whatever in a theme of a
mess affiant would often tell fishmen
would've estas unley guitarist the final
preparations and the family gathers we
on why did you tell ver from today my
son Jaden will be baptized poured out
there and we are very pleased that the
chaplain has found time for us weekends
are our daily bread when we earn our
money so he fit us in on this Wednesday
that was very kind of him we could have
waited until the winter break but we'd
rather do it now give the boy God's
blessing and then I'll feel more at ease
beneath balita
Carney's and circus folk are always on
the move so they're grateful that
somebody from the church is willing to
accompany then come up this partisan to
soreness of the site in the name of the
Father and of the Son and of the Holy
Spirit amen jayden ricardo alfredo the
community of believers receives you with
great joy and their name I sign you with
the sign of the Cross after me your
parents and godparents will trace this
sign of Christ the Redeemer on your
forehead after the baptism a family
photo family is very important to people
in this profession without the support
it provides their life would be
impossible and a baptism is an occasion
for relatives from all over the country
to gather together doesn't the reason
calls it the nasty part of a very long
dynasty going back to the 19th century I
can't even remember I'm too young I'm if
we began with acrobatics circus
performing then we got into high wire
acrobatics like 30 meters above the
ground and a wire where something could
happen at any time I don't do it anymore
I no longer see the point others still
perform high wire but if we stopped too
many things happened over the years
viennese mouth far too many things
Sophie passed yet filter field the
priest takes his leave
at a fairground in another part of
Germany Sammy is making his first
communion today he's waiting for father
Manfred when everything's ready the
children are given last minute
instructions Heidi said that got two
things will get some during mass today
you will receive for the first time the
body of Christ Christ will come to you
as the living bread you've prepared
yourselves for this day you're all
dressed for the occasion and I'll tell
you what you have to do during the mass
ok the saga Josh yeah father Manfred
zoom on runs a parish in worms from
where he ministers to the carnival
workers in his area today he has set up
his altar on the pony track that belongs
to the parents of the second child
receiving first communion LeAnn is
conveyed if I million I've known both
families for some time for as long as I
had been their chaplain I prepared the
children for their first communion and I
see the families at various fairgrounds
gradually the children's relatives
gather
father Zima knows most of them as
countable workers many are on the road
for nine months of the year feeder
commun many children make their first
communion at the fairgrounds because
there's simply no time to attend
religion classes we have our own priest
Father Zeman who comes to the grounds
visits the children and gives them
instruction I think that's great it's
wonderful we aren't fixed to one spot
we're free to move around I am injin
desi one day to Darwin's the Gonzaga
shape the Samoan keeps an eye on all our
activities he blesses the stands he is
blessed hours everything that we have
the two of us fathers Iman has blessed
for us that means against wind and
storms and everything God is with us
what is bomb he gives us strength and
protects us when we are on the road
that's very important to us this is
phones from fish dish
there are 75 thousand traveling carnival
workers and circus folk in Germany many
of their families have been in the
business for generations their homes of
the caravans and fairgrounds the priests
have to find ways in which the Christian
faith can be lived and experienced
within that context not just through the
sacraments and masks but by talking
about things in good times and in bad in
a small town near stuttgart a circus has
pitched its tense it's hot just three
hours before the family matinee at five
o'clock mother ellinghouse knows one of
the owners Stephanie Propst well hi
Lucy pedal hi there how's it going good
and you not too bad come back boy how
are things generally Oh Sonya doing
better she's come out of the coma
they're operating tomorrow yeah it's
gotta be was she conscious yeah yes when
mom asks her questions she nods or
shakes her head she understands mom says
her mind is active sure she'll bounce
back calm down
the family is feeling low Stephanie
probs sister Sonya is in hospital as a
delayed reaction to a trapeze accident
some years ago she suddenly fell into a
coma in her Caravan like many performers
she risked her life in every show the
priest is available to his flock when
they need him sometimes just spending a
few hours with them that's part of his
ministry and he's become very fond of
the prompts family we must think yes how
was yesterday anybody come in this
weather yesterday was good not the
afternoon but the evening was ok it's
normally very good here in heidenheim
familia Pope's Kenny ships on site I've
no not hopes family since 1998 when I
took some altar boys to the circus at
Christmas when we've kept in close touch
since then a common the contact became
even closer when I was appointed
chaplain to the circus and carnival
workers I call on the post six or seven
times a year and not just professionally
but it's a friend it's like visiting
relatives so I'm time I not familiar
no doubt because of the high accident
risk circus people are more aware than
others that they haven't got ultimate
control over their lives
religion and faith are very important to
many of them
father ellinghouse is warmly welcomed
when he turns up at the circus after the
performance he and Stephanie look at
some photos call for more sleazy go see
tell from this is selena's baptism have
you seen the pictures clapping I don't
think you've showed them to me now eNOS
I thought it was great that all the
artistes and workers came they came in
the right spirit and not just for the
party then what's the fiery ones it was
a beautiful celebration but life is not
simply happy memories right now they're
both worried about Sonya elianas wescam
scans which religion is tremendously
important to our family because we've
been through very hard time with my
sister my parents especially had a rough
time and my father my father was at the
end of his tether and I was also very
ill he has it that myself I know then
should we have a clown car without
religion and father ellinghouse it would
have been very hard for our family worse
than me Sean enfa in 2012 thousands of
circus people from all over the world
made their way to Rome for an audience
with the Pope Sonya Probst and her
family were among them foschini linda
dwarf Gimmerton for flogging at the
papal audience the various countries
could nominate people who had witnessed
to their faith in a special way as
travelers and from the probes circus I
nominated Stephanie's sister Sonya has a
special story as a teenager she fell
from the vertical high wire due to a
malfunction she hit her head on the
ground and of course suffered serious
injuries but after many operations she
learned to do everything again with
great enthusiasm to walk to speak to
write
she finished school function kaka
function and there's a result of this
accident she grew anything on the object
is an own file yeah im global Nocti [ __ ]
of Acts honest
miss call me oz I not absolute
pre-battle for me I come from an
absolutely private family as the
travelers say when they distinguish
themselves from the rest of the
population that is to say I don't have
any traveler's blood in me I don't know
whether I'm really a part of this
traveling world I think I'm an emissary
of the church who comes to these people
and because i like them I'm accepted and
welcomed but of course I'm not someone
who travels I have a private life a
fixed abode I wasn't born into this
family network I come from outside into
this world but I also leave this world
in the evening and return home yeah
Ostia velveeta ABS also meinem leben
from under their eyes its work
Sammy and Leanne have made their first
communion and now there's a party
there's lots to talk about when people
haven't seen each other for a long time
for Connie's the fairground is a special
place something that nobody else has the
Manfred's Iman is fond of the people
here they're bustling world which is
sometimes hard and their love of their
profession coming in available with a
long haul [ __ ] will not we they have a
lot of memories in common baptisms
weddings the death of relatives and
father seen one feels at home in this
big family farm at sanam selena galvan
tech I spent some time at a hospital in
southern Germany and at the weekend i
ventured out into the town there was a
traditional fare taking place man when I
came out of the parking garage I found
myself in front of a stand one that I
knew with some of my friends inside and
they said wow great what are you doing
here I knew lots of people there
although it wasn't in my region it felt
a little bit like going home it really
helped me over my illness that's how big
what good time and now some of those
same people are right here yes it's in
any girl here determine start on
and sometimes they're lucky enough to
get to know each other really well even
if the workers and their chaplains are
always on the move the unusual Chapel
gradually empties time for father seaman
to pack up his altar
his next task already awaits him
univision of year oh yeah harvest at the
marksman's festival in folder father
Martin Fox says mess for the members
workers and visitors celebrating Mass in
the main tent is an old tradition at
many fairs in Germany after mass he
wanders over the fairground and keeps
bumping into people he's known for years
under they are I are you well y'all I'm
fine how's business great we can't
complain sundays at the busiest day of
the week they only have time for a quick
chat but even these short encounters are
important
they never are books Canada I've known
father [ __ ] almost all my life he
baptized my son bless my newsstand 23
years ago gave my son first communion in
a tent in Nuremberg and now we're
planning his confirmation next year I'm
clava hardly anybody has come to the
fairground in the morning drizzle after
mass father ellinghouse makes his rounds
between the food booths rides and other
attractions he does this at least every
second day meeting old friends asking
after relatives the immediate family and
the extended one it's just small talk
but they know the priest is there when
they need him depend on what there's no
and I minimum
so does X hola soy Dora just five months
are you gonna go no it's all here at
YouTube and Anita my dolphins cloud move
either people don't talk about their
troubles just because the chaplain drops
by it's mostly just chatting but when
there's something important they'll say
can you step aside a minute I have
something important to tell you that
mustn't go any further and then of
course i am the confidant the rule for
which the church especially sent me the
kitchen was under her visor hunters send
in the clowns the audience doesn't
notice that one clown is missing a probs
circus the owner's daughter Sonia the
show goes on without her
after the performance father ellinghouse
chats with the performers oh noes their
way of life and their work continues to
fascinate him their vocation is to
communicate passion and joy even when
they don't feel it themselves the
pastor's vocation is to be there for
them in their world munley MIT den
circles like nachos Dylan Leslie may I
share something of the life of the
circus and carnival workers their hopes
and fears about audiences about success
and I think that people who are not able
to guarantee their own success to draw
the crowds are also more receptive to
the Word of God they know that some
things are simply not in their hands did
he thinks the eigen talked the most
important quality in a fairground
pastors that he is open to the people
they're not standoffish when the people
realize that you're accepted very
quickly by Musa interface that's gonna
have to like carnivals and fair grounds
this ministry is only possible if you
really enjoy them the rides and the
colorful world that you experience here